اعجب صوته مسلح في التاريخ واغبى حراميه
كده وصف اردنيين واقعه وابطالها يعني
فيديوهاتهم ما شاء الله منوره الاردنيين
كلهم وحتى طبعا تخطت حدود الاردن ووصلت
للعرب كلهم الموضوع كله بدا بفيديو من
كاميرات مراقبات محل الصرافه بنشوف اثنين
داخلين يسوقوا المحل
متخيلين طبعا يعني ردات الفعل على
الكوميديا اللي حصلت يعني ما ينفع نسمي
هذا السطو مسلح اصلا يا جماعه يعني
الاثنين دخلوا هددوا الموظفين بمسدس
بلاستيك ما استجابوا الموظفين قاموا حرقوا
المحل وطلعوا تخيلوا على المشهد لما
انتشرت مقاطع اضافيه من الكاميرا اللي بره
وفيها عاد لحظات الدخول والخروج كمان
شوفوا بالله طلعت الاثنين من المحل كيف
كانت
[موسيقى]
الموسيقى من عندنا مو من المقطع بس احنا
حسينا انه لازم نضيفه من كثر الدراما
شفناها في المقطع طيب من فين ابدا حقيقه
ولا بالفعل يعني من دخله الوحش اللي
داخلها على الباركينج وكيف وقف نظامي وفي
نص الشارع ولا من اللبس ان كان من الفروه
للسائق لابسها واللي واضح انها اثقل منه
ولا الشماغ على وجهه الثاني اللي طاح بعد
عشر ثواني وانكشفت هويته ولا من الكيس
اللي كان كده بكيس بلاستيك بيحط فيه
الملايين
ولا من اللياقه الخرافيه وزحلقت الاثنين
وهم طالعين مشهد كوميدي متكامل والاردنيين
طبعا ما قصروا تعليق عليه ترى والتعليقات
الابرز فين مافيات ايطاليا عن هذه المواهب
الفذه
للعلم بس الامن العام الاردني اعلن بعد
القبض عليهم بس للامانه الاثنين لازم
ينحبسوا بتهمه الغباء قبل اي تهمه ثانيه
لانه حقيقه مو معقول ابدا اللي شفناه نحن
في هذا المقطع
[موسيقى]